and and the voices that will be involved
in that process very important i'm going
to play a couple of pieces of sound from
yesterday let's start with mark murphy
on the question of what the
quarterback's role will be in the
process of selecting the new head coach
here's the ceo of the packers
you guys are just talking about aaron a
minute ago um does he have do you want
to hear what do you want to include him
in any of this stuff as far as whether
he's sitting in the interviews part of
the process
does he weigh in on this at all no no he
won't
you know obviously he's free to provide
input and talk to us but he's not going
to be part of the process
all right that's murphy who's going to
make the decision here is aaron rodgers
at his locker on monday with reporters
addressing the same question how
involved does he want to be and will he
be in the process of hiring a new coach
mark and brian and i have always had
good lines of communication
their offices like they say are always
open
i've had conversations with them like
i've had with ted over the years and
i'm not
needing to be involved in that process
before that he said he has an interest
in who the next guy will be
which you know from both guys murphy and
rogers you're getting mixed signals
input yes part of the process no i feel
like they've got this awkward balancing
act peter where they feel like they
can't have him involved or they can't
create the impression he's involved how
can he not be involved he's under
contract for five more years he's a
franchise quarterback he is the main guy
that has to have the right relationship
with the head coach how in the world do
you not involve him even if it is having
him meet with the candidates in the
presence of brian gouda kunst and mark
murphy so they can assess the chemistry
or lack thereof between rogers and the
person they're bringing through
with the possibility of that person
becoming the head coach i can't figure
out why the packers seem to be so
hesitant to state the obvious here of
course he's involved he's one of the
best quarterbacks to ever play football
and we need him to be on board with who
his next coach is
mike
when i hear those words the one thing i
think
is
well wait a second
if i'm
john d filippo of the vikings or if i'm
josh mcdaniels or or pick a guy
whoever the next coach would be
i want to talk to him
and forget about whether he wants to
talk to me i want to talk to him
because i want to know one thing
one vital thing about aaron rodgers
and that is
okay
i i'm i've watched a lot of tape of the
packers i've watched a lot of tape of
you guys and i want to know one thing do
you want to be coached do you want to be
coached hard if you ask tom brady for
instance
in new england okay if you ask him how
hard he's coached by josh mcdaniels
he'll tell you significantly
and he'll say i want to be coach that
way if you ask drew brees
about sean payton and and and pete
carmichael and joe lombardi i want to be
coached i'm coached hard and so
i want to know from aaron rodgers right
from the jump okay we're going to change
x y and z around here we might do some
rpos you're good on your feet you know
we're going to do some different things
here and i want to know are you on board
are you going to do what i believe is
best for this team so
forget about whether aaron rodgers wants
to talk to these guys if i'm these guys
i want to talk to him and i don't think
i'm taking this job unless i can talk to
him because i want to know those things
because they're very very important i
think to the future of this offense
and to the future of the green bay
packers
and that's a great point peter and he
addressed that yesterday there was a
question posed to rogers about whether
at this stage in his career he
essentially has an inclination to be his
own offensive coordinator like peyton
manning was perceived to be here's what
rogers said i enjoy being coached i
think any player does you love the
conversations the feedback and i think
any great player holds himself to really
high standards so first you have to be
very critical of your own performance
but it's always nice having a voice in
there that's going to hold you
accountable i think any player
especially an older player you want that
you want that feedback somebody holding
you accountable someone coaching you up
and it's one thing for him to say that
at his locker but i agree with you a
good coach somebody who can read people
is going to be able to have that
conversation with aaron rodgers and get
the sense in his heart is this someone
who is going to take coaching or is he
just saying all the things he thinks he
needs to say and is he going to be a
relentless pain in my ass when i try to
coach him and you're right on the money
forget about aaron rodgers involvement
the coach who is being under or who is
under consideration and being considered
for that job he needs to want to talk to
aaron rodgers because he needs to know
what he's getting himself into
mike um you know two three weeks ago i
spent saturday night with the new
orleans saints as they prepared to play
the eagles
and one of the things that was very
noticeable
when i saw the interaction of drew brees
with his teammates and the interaction
of drew brees with his coaches
he was a sponge he was a sieve he uh
sieves the wrong word sorry he was a
sponge
but drew brees was a sponge because he
wanted to know
a what do you guys think and b i like
this play what are your thoughts
and by my count mike there were 46 plays
in that game plan that drew brees
requested the night before the game hey
look these are the ones i like and i
can't tell you how many they actually
ran in a game but every single one sean
payton gave him a little bit of feedback
and said hey this is really good because
of this so i mean there was that kind of
relationship
that's the kind of relationship in my
opinion that a ceo quarterback wants
with his head coach because the
quarterback is going to go out on the
field and he's going to either have to
change the play or he's going to have to
run the play that was called
and the most important thing
is for that quarterback to believe in it
i had a stat in my column on monday mike
in which i said that aaron rodgers is on
his way
to having the most throwaways ever
since pro football focus has recorded
the statistic in 2006
and by what i mean by throwaways is you
know he's had 47 before sunday's game he
had 47. throwaways basically are you
know if you don't think the the play has
a chance you throw it into the first row
of the bleachers you throw it into the
ground whatever you know and it's almost
like if you watch aaron rodgers on some
of these and i'm reading far too much
into the ink blots into the rorschach
test here but if you watch some of these
it's like
i hate this play
yeah and again i'm i'm i'm i'm guessing
at that but that is the impression i've
had of some of these aaron rodgers
throwaways
those can't happen
if you look and see aaron rodgers
completion percentage way down this year
he's got 47 wasted balls
and and so to me mike i just look at
this he's thrown it away three and a
half times the league average you know
that has to change
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports